c'est l'heure du grand ménage pour
facebook
coca cola ben & jerry's lévis plus de
400 grandes marques ont annoncé l'arrêt
temporaire ou prolongée de leurs
investissements publicitaires sur le
réseau social
la raison une campagne de boycott lancé
le 17 juin dernier par plusieurs ong et
associations de lutte contre le racisme
comme l'anti defamation league
intitulée stop it for profite stopper la
haine pour le profit en français elle
vise à mettre fin aux contenus haineux
sur facebook
dans un long texte publié sur le site de
la campagne les organisateurs détail
leurs démarches
les réseaux sociaux ont permis à la
haine et à l'extrémisme de se propager
plus rapidement que jamais chaque jour
nos organisations sont alertés par de
nombreux exemples de messages de haine
et de désinformation diffusé sur
facebook est soutenue par des publicités
payantes
face à la grogne le mouvement pourrait
pousser certaines entreprises françaises
et européennes à suivre la tendance
une prise de conscience collective qui
frappe le réseau social au coeur
pour rappel facebook profite aujourd'hui
de quelques 8 million d'annonceurs une
véritable manne financière comme
l'indiquent le final sur le times
selon les données des marketeurs
facebook devrait générer 80 1 milliards
de dollars de revenus publicitaires
annuelles ce qui suggère qu'il engendre
environ 4,7 milliards de dollars sur une
période de trois semaines en moyenne
des sommes qui ne sont pas négligeables
pour facebook qui de son côté semble
avoir pris les choses en main le combat
contre la désinformation et les discours
et ne devrait désormais figurer au coeur
des priorités des modérateurs
c'est ce qu'a annoncé le pdg de
l'entreprise mark zuckerberg sotchi
nous adoptons donc aujourd'hui de
nouvelles politiques pour interdire une
catégorie plus large de contenus haineux
dans les publicités
plus précisément nous allons élargir
notre politique en matière de publicité
afin d'interdire les affirmations selon
lesquelles des personnes d'une race ou
une ethnie d'une origine nationale d'une
affiliation religieuse
une caste d'une orientation sexuelle
d'une identité sexuelle ou d'un statut
d'immigration spécifique ou toute
affirmation selon laquelle elle
constitue une menace pour la sécurité
physique la santé ou la survie de toute
autre personne
preuve de cette bonne volonté ce mardi
un réseau américain d'extrême droite qui
proliféraient depuis 2012 avec des
centaines de comptes à caractère haineux
a été banni de facebook peut être une
bonne nouvelle à l'heure où la
désinformation est susceptible de
gangréner la campagne pour la
présidentielle américaine de novembre
[Musique]